- Constant storm to
try to figure out
what you're about,
and you change.
At 26, you're all
about the hustle.
You're gonna be a billionaire,
this and that,
and then you go to the bar one
night, and you fall in love,
and it changes what
you care about, right,
and then you have a child,
and then this happens,
and then that happens,
things change.
You just have to always
consistently try to figure out
what's driving you, and
not because other people
are watching, and not because
that's what your dad wants,
and not because that's what
you said was gonna happen,
and it doesn't look
like it and your family's
gonna judge you, you just
have to be as real with
yourself as possible and
that is a very
difficult struggle,
but when you're not,
you create enormous
vulnerability and unhappiness.
(upbeat music)